io lo faccio con me la guerra ignare no
fino al massimo va fra casette siamo
mangiati tutti persino gli americani
apparecchio che la rapina il mio serie
dall'uomo è stato 13 ecco chi americano
magnetica ma regalo che non ci vediamo
perché viva voce cose e rubin e fare
ok
ma il celano maglia
ma velino bull ha mercato
mezzacapo lido riba mi è passato
allora molto a cuore
la mia band
mamma hanno giocato poco
e chi non mangia non può mai dire
non la pensa che ti fa ma molto porta
che la la creatura partorita mamma
voglio porto anche da sotto ma la
giornata ma di omero stati che nei primi
amici nome di dominio
io restero fine invece esce slovacca si
chiama di là
catalano parlare del sistema nato io
vado
più forti venti
ma mi ha detto da me
un altro ottimo risvegliare ma non
sbaglia in realtà meno
colpa dei montaggi si passino
ma che ha mangiato perché non esiste dal
market
e normale che un omaggio nadu hard non
esiste ma magni tutti quanti dobbiamo
mangiare tutti agendo in aula poi angela
napoli la vita
siamo beniamini sta succedendo negli
ultimi giorni
alla dell estate abbandonata
deve finire
a salvarla da questo il frutto di tutto
questo lavoro adesso vi spiego io sono
daniele de michele
ma in arte don pasta sono un salentino
giramondo facevo l'economista cosa che
ho abbandonato molto tempo fa ho sempre
fatto il dj sin da quando sono piccolo a
un certo punto però la parmigiana di
melanzane di mia nonna fulminò il mio
percorso
cioè io facevo tutte queste cose insieme
però non so come mai per uno strano
cortocircuito la parmigiana di mia nonna
che si mangia solo il 15 agosto a pranzo
invitando tanta gente si mischiò con
john coltrane
non lo so bene perché però cominciai a
raccontare questo mondo ancestrale che
era il mondo del mio salento perché per
questa cosa qua io ero cresciuto in un
sud abbandonato a vetrato
sottosviluppato
secondo l'accezione contemporanea di
sviluppo e poi andando in giro per i
vari mondi da dj tra matt economista mi
accorgevo di questa strana
dell'intendenza che più la gente si
arricchiva civilizzata in un certo senso
più perdeva la memoria
allora io non capivo quanto fosse
possibile nel momento in cui tu diventi
più sano più civilizzato dai
emancipazione ai lavoratori come puoi
perdere delle informazioni di te della
tua identità nel momento in cui queste
sono per me le accezioni fondamentali
per riconoscere che cosa sia il cibo
allora io sono cresciuto ho fatto il mio
l'artista faccio l'artista girando
facendo uno spettacolo in cui cucino
metto musica lo faccio ormai da più di
12 13 anni che cosa è successo nel
frattempo che il linguaggio della cucina
che era prima un linguaggio o popolare o
molto tecnico e diventato di massa e
piano piano abbiamo assistito una
mediatizzazione molto grande e del cibo
che in sé portava una alienazione del
sapere allora che significa che tu
normalmente prima avevi una concezione
della cucina popolare italiana basata su
un sapere diffuso dalla maggior parte
delle persone spesso analfabeti spesso
in dialetto concepivano e riproducevano
un piatto tradizionale trasformandolo in
piatto proprio quindi identitario
individuale e collettivo di quel luogo
attraverso un meccanismo di passaggio e
di sapere orizzontale già nel novecento
con il talismano della felicità e il
cucchiaio d'argento la codificazione
della cucina italiana è passata da
un'idea larghe orizzontale a un'idea di
progetto fai così metti questi g fa in
questo modo questi sono i tempi cosa che
non è mai esistita nella cucina popolare
da cucina popolare non ti da precetti ti
porta a capire deduttivamente come si
cucina un piatto e come spiegare
all'altra persona che sia tuo figlio
oppure che siano le i tuoi vicini come
tu fai quella cosa lì questo processo
piano piano è andato a scomparire
passando dal talismano della felicità al
cucchiaio d'argento poi passando dalla
ultra tecnologia e le spietate dell'as
per azione della qualità di slowfood
coldiretti italy fino a passare al
diciamo alla mediatizzazione selvaggia
di masterchef in cui praticamente si
sostituisce un linguaggio comune con un
linguaggio globalizzato uguale ovunque
in qualsiasi parte del mondo in cui tu
vai gradita dalla massaia che il
soffritto in cui davide vi date sapeva
qualcosa va sostituito con la riduzione
di scalogno se no sei uno sfigato
allora questa cosa qua si chiama
alienazione marziana cioè tu togli un
sapere e lo sostituisce con qualcosa che
tu non di cui non ha il dominio di cui
non conosce le cause nelle conseguenze
come fare l'unica cosa che io potevo
fare era partire da artusi a cui si era
un nobile dell'ottocento che si pose la
questione di come salvaguardare e
codificare il
patrimonio della cucina italiana
beninteso il patrimonio della cucina
italiana e una cucina di poveri che
sapevano con tre quattro ingredienti
soddisfare la regola fondamentale
dell'italiano che mangiare con gusto e
tu dovevi farlo col 34 ingredienti al
massimo spesso che è l'esatto opposto
delle cucine che ci vengono raccontati
in questo modo in questo momento
ovviamente lui come poteva farlo si nava
massimo montanari alla metafora e dice
che lui era il primo blogger perché lui
riceveva le lettere le verificava con
marietta che la sua assistente e una
volta che l'aveva verificate le
raccontava e tu come fai per raccontato
una ricetta mi dici le dosi e le
preparazioni no lui capì
intelligentemente che per raccontare il
patrimonio italiano amato in tutto il
mondo
tu non dovevi dirmi come fare un piatto
to me tu al massimo vi spieghi come tu
l'hai fatto e lui spesso si rifiutava di
dare le dosi
lui ti raccontava le essenze il senso le
emozioni di quel piatto cosa che non si
è più fatta allora ho detto per poter
fare una fotografia di quello che si è
salvato
non per fare una fotografia di una
tradizione che sta scomparendo ma per
vedere quelle cose là quanto diventano
dinamiche e quanto sono dinamiche nella
contemporaneità andava fatto
un'operazione simile quindi sono andato
al comitato scientifico di casa artusi
da massimo montanari alberto capatti gli
ho detto ma io posso lavorare sul
patrimonio italiano senza parlare di
tradizione e loro ridendo mi in faccia
dicono artusi non ha mai usato la parola
tradizione ha usato il concetto di
cucina quotidiana familiare e della ho
capito che effettivamente questa era la
chiave di osservazione della realtà
quindi che ho fatto ho fatto un colpo se
non a chiamata alle armi e ho scritto
via facebook twitter e via web a per
telefono mandateli le ricette mandatemi
le ricette quelle soprattutto che
scivolano dai ricettari delle nonne
quelli scritti a mano perché perché io
come potevo verificare
l'esattezza di una ricetta cioè noi
abbiamo non è una fase in un'epoca
storica in cui basta iscriviti dei
limiti arrivano 40 ricetta quindi uno
bastava chimico piazza la ricetta da
internet e me la mandava ma io partendo
da questi presupposti che cosa volevo
salvare perché a quel puntino di gettare
sulla cucina italiana basato sul lavoro
di artusi mi bastava mettere il la
ricetta del tortellino come dice
d'accademia del tortellino no perché a
me interessava sapere quanto fosse vivo
ancora il meccanismo cognitivo dietro
una costruzione di una ricetta e quindi
chiedevo chi sei che ricetta mi dai
perché mi dai quella ricetta
questa cosa mi permetteva di arrivare
alla conclusione che il cibo era corpo
che liberamente introiezione di tutto
quello che è il simbolo di una ricetta e
quindi ho raccolto queste ricette e poi
le verificavo come poterle verificare
con i ricettari ovviamente storici ma
anche sul web su facebook dicevo mioni
napoletani ma non è noto sta ricetta
della genovese secondo voi ecco perché
corretta e succedeva il finimondo da
questo finimondo io riuscivo a fare la
cernita delle informazioni corretto non
corretta
questo è stato il lavoro che s'impone
veramente il la questione etica di che
fare del patrimonio della cucina
italiana perché così sono scompare e
l'ho fatto nei vari modi e l'ho fatto
con questo libro con quel blog l'ho
fatto con con uno spettacolo
multimediale che porto in giro e il mio
sogno riuscire mai terminato a farne un
film
quindi questo è il lavoro io vi lascerei
giusto e con con la conclusione di
questa di questo lavoro che per
spiegarvi un po come com'è andata a
finire
mangiare è come respirare senza timore
non può e non potrà essere una cosa da
trattare alla leggera
io non poteva pagarmi il diritto di
parlare della cucina italiana da solo
non ne sarei stato in grado
doveva essere una cosa corale perché
corale è la cucina italiana
avevo paura prima di iniziare paura che
tutto forse persa per sempre di una
cucina familiare che nessuno ha più il
tempo né la voglia di fare che a mio
figlio non potessi lascia nulla in dono
del mio essere uomo di sud è un uomo in
italia come pellegrino artusi mi sono
appellato a tanta gente ed è stato bello
ricevere ricette senza g senza
indicazioni precise nessuno che mi dessi
g quanto basta quanto basta però tutti
sapevano usare le parole belle di quando
si parla della cucina della propria
storia
in quella lettera non c'era niente di
patetico e di tradizionalista di
malinconico ma c'è un problema
nulla è per sempre
bisogna scegliere tutti assieme se valga
la pena a conservare un patrimonio
infinito o vederlo scomparire a fruire
di reinventare alleggerire
infiocchettare e fare riduzioni di
scalogno che il cibo resti lontano dalle
mode dai tecnicismi che resti linguaggio
di ognuno che ci si accorga in ogni
istante della storia che c'è dietro
patrimonio fatto di donne che hanno
raccolto chili e chili di pomodori e
limoni hanno raccolto il riso nell'acqua
per ora è fatto figli grandi e forti che
resti cibo dell'anima dunque cura
profonda cura per i propri cari
nell'offrire ciò che si ama a qualcuno
che si ama a mio figlio a ogni bimbo e
bimba che sappiano che una delle rivolte
più belle e quella di non essere mai
uguali agli altri e che per farlo è
bello conservare ogni singola traccia
della diversità che abbiamo ricevuto in
dono con questa cucina perché grazie a
questa sappiamo che nella vita non
bisogna
può darsi mai mai passivamente alle
regole alle leggi imposte alle abitudini
e alla globalizzazione dei gusti che
ogni cosa cancella perché la cucina
italiana nel suo essere geniale a
partire da nulla ci ha aiutato a vivere
con dignità nella disoccupazione nelle
ingiustizia
durante regimi infami nelle migrazioni
nella guerra e nella fame proteggiamoci
soffriggete grazie